very soon we will all be getting
together and celebrating the
Thanksgiving season with friends and
family and one of the best feelings is
knowing that from top to bottom your
carpet Talent grout upholstery even your
air ducts have been professionally
cleaned by our friends at Zerorez and
Ben McKee from Zerorez the sponsors of
this next segment along with Doug and
they're here to help remind us that you
need to call and make those appointments
today am I right this is the day we're
gonna get booked up so
give us a call we'll get you a place
spotless for you it really does make a
difference and you obviously do carpets
which we're going to show you an example
of their work here in a second but one
thing I really want to focus on that's
really important is air quality in your
home and you guys do air ducts too we do
our whole approach is just improving is
to improve the indoor air quality of
your home or your business and that
starts out with getting your carpets
cleaned it's the biggest air filter in a
home believe it or not and we could top
it off with cleaning your ductwork with
the greatest and latest technology now
if you make an appointment do you have
to make two separate appointments one
for air ducts one for carpet or can you
do it all in one visit we could do it
all in one visit whatever is easiest for
you just give us a call we can answer
those questions for you and figure out
what specifically helps you out it
really does change everything I feel
like I can breathe easier when you guys
come into my home let's show them a
little bit Doug of what we've got going
on here Ben you guys always dirty up
this carpet we do and then you come in
and let's uh it's called The One swipe
magic
um look at this I know it's it's magic
and it looks like we got Magic Water
this water this is our gr water
technology that has no soaps no
chemicals no or no harsh chemicals no
surfactants it's just the power of water
and that is amazing to me because it
dries faster because there's no soap
that gets sticky in there and then also
and your kids and anyone else that is in
there definitely I've got two little
ones at home and I'm you know concerned
about what are they crawling on when
they're going on on a carpets and with
zero res it's completely safe and the
best thing is it's effective you can see
the difference that it makes you
mentioned businesses too businesses can
call you up you can come in there and
clean up absolutely whether you got
convention space hotels or a little
office we can get you cleaned up let's
talk about the deal that you're going to
offer for our viewers it's my holiday
season my favorite time of year so right
now you get three rooms of carpet clean
for only 119 and we're gonna throw throw
in a free family pass to the glittering
lights oh that is unheard of love it you
guys always offer the best deals thank
you guys so much dear res you guys are
the best thank you for sponsoring this
segment and take advantage of that
holiday sale again it's three rooms of
carpet clean for only 119 plus that free
family pass to glittering lights that
drive through lights display at the Las
Vegas Motor Speedway you can call
702-840-333 or go online to
zerorezlasvegas.com for more information
minimums apply